we're now in the first week of july two
thousand sixteen so it's time for
another monthly update video in which I
talk about what went on during the month
of june and what we've got coming up in
the month of july so as usual i like to
begin by talking about three big things
putting these on your radar from the
start i'll talk more about them as we go
deeper into the discussion of june and
july but the first big thing is we have
a new class coming out with reason i owe
entirely online Epictetus is enchiridion
and discourses a text to text that i've
been working with for over 20 years I've
taught in classroom settings and online
for quite a long time starting july
twenty fourth its enrolling we've
already filled up some of the seats so
i'm very excited about that but more
about that later the second big thing is
that in the half hour hagel project
which you might know I've been doing for
now about two and a half years producing
these half hour long videos going
through eventually the entirety of
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit we are
now right about here so we're starting a
new section and so that's always a lot
of fun and this is a really interesting
section in which Hagel is going to
tackle some of the pseudo-sciences of
his time physiognomies and phrenology
but it's got some very important
implications for contemporary you know
let's not call them pseudoscience is
quite yet but so the third thing then is
that back in June I gave a talk in which
I I made an excursion into a field that
for me I've had a long-standing interest
in but I haven't done any presentations
in up until this point and that is
astronomy I gave a talk and a tasting on
the eight that's eight not four but
eight basic tastes of food that we're
recognizing
in the Western tradition from Aristotle
all the way up until about the 18th
century so I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a few minutes so what went
on during the month of june I didn't get
quite as much done as I had hoped for or
plan to insignificant part because my
kids were here for the summer so we did
a lot of family things I cut back on
most days to no more than four hours of
work per day and given that i'm usually
putting in anywhere from from eight to
fourteen that's that's a significant
reduction we also had some family
medical issues arise during the month as
well so that that took up quite a bit of
time I did give a number of talks most
of which you can actually see on the
videos that I've linked to hear the
first one was in that that science
fiction and fantasy series that I've
been doing with the Brookfield public
library as my yearly series and it was
on Frank Herbert's dune universe we had
some great attendance we also had
somebody bring some of the original
copies of the analog magazine in which
the the dune novel was was serialized so
that was really cool then we had a half
hour hagel online Q&A session we do that
monthly as well some great discussion
and towards the end of the month we have
the eight basic tastes of food hosted by
the whitefish bay library we we actually
didn't just deliver an academic talk or
a popular talk this was much more
oriented towards a popular audience we
did a tasting with it and you can watch
the video for that I also put a link to
the blog entry that i wrote discussing
that and if you want you can replicate
the tasting yourself by finding the
items that we
used for contemporary items that are
pretty easy to find and then towards the
very end of the month I went to a
conference here in Milwaukee at
Marquette University just just down the
street from us the Aristotle and
Aristotelian is a resilient tradition
conference it was really great I met a
lot of people including some some big
names who I've been writing for years
and years and I also presented my own
research there I didn't have the paper
completely finished so I presented some
of it in the form of notes and it was on
Aristotle's views on Acra co that is
lack of self control with respect to
anger so that was a great great occasion
as far as coursework goes we finished
our Aristotle nikka McCann ethics online
class will be offering that again later
on but for the for the present what I'm
concentrating on is the Plato's
symposium class that I'm currently
teaching and then getting the Epictetus
class ready to roll we open it up a
little bit ahead of time so people can
poke around in their video work I I only
got three half hour hagel videos done
but that's okay because i closed out
that that section in observing reason
which only required three videos i've
been releasing the aristotle core
concept videos i also finished releasing
the last of the and some mona logie own
videos as well and we took videos of the
events with the exception of the across
iya due to anger talk which really
wouldn't have fit in while to try to
video record that i din some
philosophical counseling and some
coaching no tutoring because i think
people are kind of done with that for
the summer but i'm sure that will be
picking up quite a bit in the fall and
we've done a bit of planning but that's
really about the bulk of what what went
on during during june so in many
respects as far as work goes kind of a
slow month so what's coming up for the
month
july we've got several different talks
all of which are either here or online
i'll be doing o'clock july fourteenth
that's bastille day at seven p.m. at the
brookfield public library in that
science fiction and fantasy series this
time talking about Roger Zelazny 'he's
chronicles of amber the first five books
although i'm sure some people will have
come and have read all the rest of them
and the prequels and all that and i'm
talking about amber and chaos and I'm
tying it together with some themes from
neoplatonism and from Nietzsche so that
should be quite interesting July
twentieth 5 p.m. central time the reason
I mentioned central time is because this
is an online event so you know most
people are not in this time zone we will
be having our half hour Hagel public Q&A
session so you know if you've got any
Hagel related questions anything you're
confused about and if you're reading
Hagel you probably ought to be confused
about Suffolk it is pretty confusing
come to the session and I'll field
whatever questions I can I'm always
happy to help out that way july twenty
seventh and other local event here with
the wauwatosa library i was asked to
come back and give another talk on
existentialism so the first talk we gave
I think back in March is sort of a
general overview of who were the
existentialist this time I'm going to
focus on a key theme within
existentialism the relationship between
anxiety and human freedom so we'll be
talking you know as you can guess about
some some Kierkegaard some Heidegger
some sort but other people as well so
that's going to be quite interesting
probably i don't have it in the event
description but we'll smuggle in some
chef stuff because i always like to do
him courses we're finishing up the
Plato's symposium course which has been
going quite well we're in Week three
right now and we should be finishing up
week for by the midpoint of the month
then we're starting the epictetus
enchiridion and discourses course that's
a six-week online course starting july
twenty fourth with an introductory
session the class meets for class
sessions on saturdays and i actually
scheduled them at two different times in
the day so that people in different time
zones or with different kinds of work
schedules can make it to those classes
there's a link below if you're
interested in enrolling in the class in
finding out more about the class or in
getting on our mailing list to you know
find out about future course offerings
we're going to be giving a lot of these
in the future not just on the ones we've
done before but meecha is coming up
tante is coming up and some is coming up
all sorts of cool things going on in any
case the epictetus class getting ready
to start that and i imagine we'll
probably get a significant demand so we
might even consider opening up a second
section if there's a sufficient demand
for the class some writing projects I've
got going on so I'm working right now
still on the the last bits of a stoicism
today post which will be coming out
later this week on epictetus and dealing
with one's own anger I did a post on
other people's anger now you know it's
time to talk about one's own anger got
some stuff coming out in our exes do
know NTK a blog that I started years ago
and I have not been able to spend as
much time on as i would have liked but
now i'm getting it back in gear half
hour Hagel I've got some interesting
content coming up in there including the
follow-up piece about Hagel and stoicism
I'm going to be hopefully logging a bit
for the partially examined life as well
and I'm working on some academic
projects as well I'm trying to get some
work done on the Aristotle an anger book
I'm working on a more popularly oriented
book that I've got in in sort of
skeletal form on Aristotle in the
virtues I've got to get the art
done on a cross iya due to anger and I
had a long overdue piece that I
presented and I'm still reworking that I
presented it back in the fall and I owe
it to the Marcel people on Gabriella
Marcel and jean-paul sartre as
existentialist interlocutors so i'll be
working on those things over the course
of the month got some coaching and
philosophical counseling appts already
lined up and i imagine that the calendar
is going to start filling up with more
of those so we've got quite a few of
these things going on so I'm through
reason I owe some through priority
thinking very happy it's a part of the
profession that I I really enjoy I
should probably do a video about that
down the line about just you know what
is philosophical counseling what is
coaching and why do I particularly enjoy
it but but I'll just sort of leave it at
there so that is pretty much the the
plan for the month ahead this is a
somewhat shorter video again in part
because I'll be spending less time on
academic and other professional pursuits
and a bit more time engaged with some
some family things and some just you
know downtime and fun but there's
there's actually quite a bit lined up
for them on the head and then August is
going to be a really major month for us
so we're gearing up and doing some
planning and laying groundwork for that
so hope you're enjoying your your
summertime or if you're in the southern
hemisphere your winter and have a good
month